RISKING FULL SCALE WAR WITH
NATO.
SOCIAL KNEAD MEDIA ISN'T
HELPING.
IT'S HARD TO KNOW WHAT TO
BELIEVE ANYMORE.
LIVING IN AN INFORMATION AGE AT
OUR FINGERTIPS.
THERE ARE SERIOUS DOUBTS OVER
WHICH PARTS OF IT ARE TRUE.
>> MOSCOW WAS INCREASINGLY USING
HARSH TACTICS TO CONTROL
INFORMATION ABOUT WAR.
THIS INCLUDED JAILING
JOURNALISTS.
>> THEY AIMED AT BRINGING
BELARUS INTO THE CONFLICT.
THE BIOLOGICAL WEAPONS ARE
BECOMING A KEY PART OF THE
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN
TO JUSTIFY INVADING UKRAINE.
DAN: THEY TWIST THE TRUTH.
BUT THE LEFT HERE IS ENGAGED IN
INFORMATION DISINFORMATION, TOO.
LET'S START WITH THE
SELF-PROCLAIMED GAIT KEEPERS
TRUTH -- GATEKEEPER OF TRUTH.
ACCORDING TO THE FACT CLERKS AT
POLITIFACT, THE U.S. DID NOT
DOUBLE OIL IMPORTS FROM RUSSIA
IN THE LAST YEAR.
WELL, NIGHT TRY.
IT TURNS OUT THE UNITED STATES
DID DOUBLE ITS CRUDE OIL IMPORTS
FROM RUSSIA IN 2021.
HERE IS THE JOKE OF THIS WHOLE
THING.
POLITIFACT EVEN MENTIONED THAT
IN THE TENTH PARAGRAPH ITS
ORIGINAL STORY.
FAIL NUMBER TWO.
WHEN THE WHOLE WORLD SAW JOE
BIDEN CHECK HIS WATCH DURING THE
CEREMONY HONORING THE FALLEN
U.S. SERVICE MEMBERS WHO DIED IN
AFGHANISTAN.
"USA TODAY" UNLEASHED ITS FACT
CHECKING ARMY.
THE PAPER HAD TO WRITE A
CORRECTION AFTER THEIR OWN FAKE
FACT CHECK.
FACT CHECKER FAIL NUMBER THREE.
REMEMBER BEFORE THE KYLE
RITTENHOUSE TRIAL POLITIFACT
INSISTED IT WAS PERFECTLY LEGAL
FOR RIGHT HOUSE TO CARRY A GUN?
FALSE.
DURING THE TRIAL THE JUDGE
DISMISSED THE CHARGE AGAINST
RITTENHOUSE AND THE FACT
CHECKERS SCRAMBLED TO EXPLAIN
THEIR MISTAKE.
THEY HAVE ONE JOB, TO KEEP US
INFORMED WITH THE TRUTH.
YOUR ONE JOB AND YET YOU KEEP
FAILING OVER AND OVER.
BUT THE TIDE MAY BE TURNING.
ESPECIALLY IN THE COVID
INFORMATION WAR.
SOME VACCINATION RULES ARE STILL
INTACT.
NEW YORK WON'T ALLOW
UNVACCINATED HOME TEAMS TO PLAY.
BUT THEY WILL ALLOW UNVACCINATED
TEAMS TO MAY IN NEW YORK.
>> I DON'T CARE HOW COVID
COMPLIANCE YOU ARE.
CAN WE AGREE ON THAT.
THAT.THAT?
KYRIE CAN GO INSIDE AND WATCH
BUT HE CAN'T PLAY.
DAN: PEOPLE LIKE US WERE GETTING
POKED FUN AT FOR BRINGING IT UP.
KEVIN DURANT SAID IT BEST.
>> I JUST FEELS LIKE AT THIS
POINT NOW, IT REFLECTS THEIR
AUTHORITY.
EVERYONE IN THE WORLD.
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING
ON.
NOW IT'S JUST STUPID.
DAN: SEE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
PEOPLE WAKE UP TO PROPAGANDA?
KEVIN DURANT THINKS THE RULES
ARE STUPID BECAUSE THEY ARE
STUPID.
THERE COULD BE MORE BAD NEWS
COMING UP FOR THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS.
HAS ANYONE ASKED WHY WE ARE NOT
SEEING THE SAME OUTBREAK IN THE
UNITED STATES?
HAVE WE OBTAINED HERD IMMUNITY,
THE SAME HERD IMMUNITY THAT IS
CALLED UNREALISTIC BY THE MEDIA?
>> ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT HERD
IMMUNITY?
IT'S ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
RHETORIC ABOUT HERD IMMUNITY.
>> THAT NOT A FUNDAMENTAL
STRATEGY.
>> I DON'T DO PROPAGANDA SO I
CAN'T PROVE WE REACHED HERD
IMMUNITY.
BUT HERD IMMUNITY IS NOT A
STRATEGY.
IT'S A PHENOMENON.
GO TO THE SEARCH MACHINE ON THE
INTERNET AND LIKE THE UP.
IT ISN'T A TALKING POINT.
IT'S NOT FACT CHECKERS FAILING
US AND THE MEDIA FAILING US.
THE LEFT'S HYPOCRISY IS GETTING
WORSE.
REMEMBER WHEN HILLARY CLINTON
ACCUSED TULSI GABBARD OF BEING
USED BY THE RUSSIANS?
TULSI GABBARD, RUSSIAN STOOGE.
EVERYBODY IS A RUSSIAN STOOGE IF
YOU ARE NOTE A DEMOCRAT BUTT
KISSER.
NOW THEY ARE SAYING SHE TOOK
2020 CAMPAIGN DONATIONS FROM A
RUSSIAN AGENT FOR AN AMICING
$59.95.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A DOOR DASH BILL
ON THE WEEKEND.
BUT THE LEFT SOMEHOW FORGETS HB
HUNTER BIDEN'S LAVISH GIFTS.
HE WAS GIVEN A 3 CARAT GEM.
NO WAY.
FOLKS, BETWEEN THE FAILED FACT A
CHECKERS AND THE STREA